[Musique]
alors c'est vrai au début on pensait ne
pas être là aujourd'hui
et pourtant ce n'est pas parce que nous
avons failli frôler la mort en essayant
de traverser la manche en duo ou bien en
essayant d'escalader l'une des faces les
plus ardus de l'everest
non c'est juste qu'elle a vu du mail de
tadic nous annonçant qu'on avait été
sélectionnée pour parler aujourd'hui on
a largement envisagé de ne jamais s'ils
répondent à cause de la paresse
symptomatique des jeunes n'ont pas
vraiment plutôt par une remise en
question est ce que nous avions vraiment
quelque chose d'intéressant à raconter
et surtout sommes-nous légitime pour
parler devant une large audience
l'aspiration d'un tadjiks et de partager
des idées pour changer le monde
ça ça nous parle des idées nous en avons
plein et cette envie de changer le monde
aussi et vous savez quoi
on est sûr que vous aussi tout le monde
partage cette aspiration
on a tous des idées qui valent à peine
d'être partagée alors pourquoi en
théorie tout s'explique
mais en pratique tout se complique
pourquoi aussi peur de nous exprimer
la peur est un instinct de survie
un mécanisme de défense face au danger
mais sommes-nous vraiment en danger
la main plan avant que l'ensemble du
public décide de monter sur scène pour
exprimer son mécontentement
on est plutôt sec ça vous n'avez pas
l'air trop peu trop agressif pour
l'instant pourtant nous voilà face à une
situation nouvelle et pas franchement
rassurante on vous la corde
oui le type de situation auquel on est
tous confrontés un jour vous savez ce
moment précis où l'on devrait être
n'importe où ailleurs plutôt qu'ici est
bien pour nous c'est un peu maintenant
mais ne vous inquiétez pas on va pas
partir en cours on sait assez préparés
psychologiquement en plus à deux la peur
est partagé vous voyez dans la vie c'est
toujours bien d'avoir un peu de soutien
mais pas besoin pour autant d'avoir un
meilleur ami qui partage exactement la
même vision du monde que vous nous même
sommes d'accord dans approximativement 0
% la discussion est d'ailleurs tu
l'étais pas vraiment d'accord pour
combattre cette phrase là quoi qu'il en
soit l'une des réactions les plus
raisonnables
face à la peur c'est de faire face à la
situation avec lucidité dans l'immense
majorité des cas personne ne risque une
mort subite
mais pourtant une fois ce danger-là a
écarté une appréhension reste celle de
l'échec
pourquoi pensez que nous n'en serions
pas capables que nous ne serions pas à
la hauteur tous ces doutes viennent d'un
manque de confiance en soi d'une peur de
la prise de risque
c'est vrai sans confiance on prend pas
de risques sans prendre de risque on
n'obtient jamais la satisfaction d'avoir
su oser
bonne chance pour sortir le cercle
vicieux a alors pour changer le monde il
faut déjà se changer soi même
oui aux et s'est passé par un
cheminement de lâcher prise
c'est se déconnecter de toutes les
issues possibles de nos actes et c'est
aussi se rendre compte que l'on ne peut
pas changer ou influencer certaines
choses aux essais continuer à parler
même si la moitié de la salle et plus
fasciné par son téléphone que par vos
propos exemple quoi qu'il en faut
l'autre chose qui peut bloquer la prise
de parole c'est le sentiment de ne pas
être la personne la plus apte à
s'exprimer en effet on pense que l'on
manque d'expérience et du coup qu'on
n'est pas les plus légitimes
on rêverait d'avoir quelque chose de
beau et de grand impressionnant a
raconté on regretterait presque ne pas
avoir failli frôler la mort lors de
notre ascension
alors c'est vrai on n'a pas d'expérience
profonde
on n'est ni l'expert en haute montagne
ni celui qui a escaladé l'everest neuf
fois on remarque ici que ce qui semble
compter dans la réflexion individuelle
et aussi dans l'opinion publique
c'est l'argument d'autorité celui de
l'expert s'est affirmé que j ai raison
parce que cela a été dénoncé par un
spécialiste
en effet c'est vrai on accorde tous
beaucoup plus de crédit à quelqu'un dont
c'est le domaine d'expertisé
vous ne comprenez pas votre vie d'ange
un euro s'échangeait 1 par exemple
pourtant celui-ci peut tout à fait avoir
d'innombrables vidange à son action 26
ainsi on remarque donc qu'on accorde
beaucoup d'importance à l'expert mais
aussi à celui qui a expérimenté c'est
celui qui a appris de son vécu et cela
le rend cela le rend légitime en tant
que jeune c'est de type d'expérience
nous pose un problème on n'a pas assez
vécu on n'a pas assez expérimenté pour
changer le monde
on n'a pas non plus étudiée assez
longtemps pour être parfaitement sûrs de
nous mais ce problème ne nous concerne
pas que nous verse factuelle est jeune
mais il concerne chacun d'entre nous on
a tous des sujets avec lesquels on est
plus ou moins familiers cependant
experts et expérimenté en tout genre
êtes vous vraiment des experts de votre
expertise la légitimité d'opinion ne se
base pas seulement sur le vécu si un
sujet vous intéresse que vous en
comprenez les enjeux
c'est assez pour en parler en effet
lorsqu'il s'agit d'opinions
le but n'est pas d'être le meilleur des
experts il faut oser croire et défendre
en ce qui nous tient à coeur
tout en acceptant le débat il faut
savoir se dépasser repousser ses limites
pour faire valoir ses opinions
quoi qu'il en soit si chacun n'a pas
forcément directement agi pour changer
le monde
tout le monde a la volonté de
l'influencé par ses opinions et le but d
information et autres expertises réside
dans leur diffusion
regardez nous comme pas mal de jeunes
avons quelques années dans le système
scolaire et des heures passées sur
internet c'est derrière nous enfin bon
remarquer c'était assez à mark
zuckerberg pour influencer petite partie
du monde informatique et ce même avant
l'âge légal requis pour pouvoir voter
lui même n'est d'ailleurs pas pu
légitime qu'un autre pour donner son
avis sur quoi que ce soit sauf peut-être
sur ce que ça fait de venir super riches
avant ses 25 ans m enfin quoiqu'il en
soit c'était un exemple précis mais
revenons à nous saisissons nous de cette
occasion pour prendre la parole mais on
les confronte à un problème de quoi
parler on est toujours plus à l'aise
pour parler d'un sujet que l'on maîtrise
que l'on connaît qu'on a confronté si
beaucoup de sujet pourrait être abordé
parlons d'un qui nous rassemble tous
l'humanité on voit ce mot un peu partout
et avec une multitude de sens différent
mais qu est-ce qu mann heat et peut
vraiment dire en bonne contemporaine du
21e siècle
nous nous sommes immédiatement saisie de
notre navigateur internet favoris
la première définition d' humanité c'est
celle de l'appartenance au genre humain
à une communauté plus grande que celle
d'une nation par exemple jusque là ça va
on était plutôt d'accord sur la
définition mais le deuxième sens
d'humanité est synonyme de compassion et
de bienveillance
là on vous avoue ça nous a posé quelques
problèmes parce que si l'humanité
désigne en même temps un groupe
d'individus et aussi de la bienveillance
on ne retrouve pas systématiquement ces
deux termes associés autour de leur
histoire et actualité nous ont bien
appris qu humain et humanité à l'effort
plus ensemble bon en même temps si
depuis notre plus jeune âge on nous
apprend à être le meilleur parmi tous
nos petits camarades
on part déjà sacrément désavantagé dans
la course à la gentillesse dès l'école
maternelle
dès l'école maternelle on nous berce
avec les notions de travail et de
compétition prouvé en beau métier
apparaît comme le plus juste
refrain final souvent des valeurs nous
sont inculquées sans que conscience ne
soit impliquée mais le pire dans tout
cela c'est que lorsque vous êtes une
fille levis va jusque chercher la
perfection de votre être même
oui enfin bon on remarquera ici que
votre être c'est plutôt votre part être
parce que quand on est une fille ce qui
semble plus compter c'est votre
apparence un peu comme les fruits
supermarché quoi au boeuf aussi ce qu'il
faut retenir quand on est une fille
c'est qu'il est très important de
maîtriser imparfaite et qu'il il faut
être féminine mais pas trop il faut
prendre soin de soi sans être trop
superficiel on est trop narcissique ni
trop négligé il faut se maquiller et
jamais en excès possibles dans sa bile
sans être trop vulgaire ni trop prude et
trop adulte ni trop enfantine il faut
paraître vulnérables fragiles délicate
mais pas trop bon c'est un peu difficile
de créer une humanité sans division man
nous ce qu'on aimerait s'y est tout
simplement que l'humanité répondent à la
définition qu'elle se donne et peut-être
que pour créer un peu plus d'humanité
il faudrait accorder la parole aux
jeunes qui sont peu représentées dans
notre société
même à ceux qui comme nous n'ont pas
révolutionné leurs airs et sur ce point
les réseaux sociaux ont permis
l'impensable permettre aux hommes de
faire deux choses à la fois
[Musique]
envoyée mais en même temps recevoir des
informations
mais comment c'est l' éthique dont
possible sur un ton tout à pully ainsi
on se sent plus concerné chacun peut
donner son avis très rapidement ainsi à
l'instant même où une information nous
parvient on peut y réagir on peut aussi
partager nos idées à bien plus grande
échelle
cependant cette situation est paradoxale
en effet aujourd'hui on n'a jamais été
plus connectés mais on n'a jamais été
aussi seul qui avait déjà connu un genre
de solitude asie brutal mais l'
isolement dans cette fourmilière
américaine prenait une tournure plus
accablantes encore bon pour les amateurs
de littérature vous aurez peut-être
connu céline dont on ne retiendra que
les mots ici qu ici la fourmilière
américaine de céline c'est devenu notre
pays en effet maintenant quand on arrive
sur les réseaux sociaux on voit le champ
des possibles s'ouvrir l'humanité semble
à portée de main
devenir polyglotte trouver l'amour de
votre vie tout savoir sur le petit
cousin du beau-frère de votre mieux tout
cela sent bien possible mais pourtant
face à l'immensité des possibilités que
l'on peut trouver sur le net
la réalité nous sommes levitt bien fait
en effet et le rapport que l'on a avec
les réseaux sociaux nous renvoie à la
perception que l'on a de nous mêmes très
vite on se sent plus à la hauteur et on
essaie donc de renvoyer la meilleure
image que l'on a
quitte parfois à ce père et forcément
cela amène en manque un déficit de
confiance en soi
alors que runner pour nous jeunes jolies
et toujours en vie vient comme un mantra
auxquelles se raccrocher jeunes oui nous
le sommes
est ce que nous en perdons ne serait ce
qu'une once de légitimité
certainement pas
jolie oui on l'est et on reprend
possession de ce mot même notre physique
ne devrait jamais être un obstacle à
notre épanouissement personnel et même
si on ne correspond pas aux idéaux
irréalisable de la société on a le droit
en cette confiance en soi plus ainsi oui
on l'est assurément
et c'est déjà bien assez osé parler pour
changer le monde
c'est notre défi aujourd'hui dépassée
lauper s'ouvrir aux autres et donner
notre avis nous voulons vous partagez ce
à quoi l'on croit même si changer la
perception du monde de toute la salle
est certes un peu compliqué en
convaincre quelques-uns est déjà bien
assez
alors osons osé parler pour changer le
monde
merci
[Applaudissements]